good morning
bitterly disappointing pitiful a kick in
the teeth
this is how union leaders have described
a one percent pay rise being proposed by
the government for nhs staff
the department for health and social
care has defended the offer
saying it needed to strike the right
balance between pay and
staff numbers but health leaders are
accusing the government
of being out of touch and called it an
insult to those who have stepped up to
tackle the coronavirus crisis as our
chief political correspondent john craig
reports
boris johnson and rishi sunak regularly
clapped for carers
during the covid pandemic last year
but now they're being accused of
insulting nhs workers
by proposing a pay rise of just one
percent
when inflation is forecast to rise to
1.7 percent
the offer which labor claims is a pay
cut could mean an increase of just 3
pounds
50 a week extra take-home pay
for experienced nurses such as those at
this west london hospital
it is a bit of a slap in the face i mean
like all we've had this year is
claps and not really we were struggling
with pp in the
beginning but um yeah it doesn't really
feel
like it's enough i'm not really happy
about it considering what has happened
with with the covet all of us are just
feeling burnt out and i feel like one
percent isn't really enough
there's anger too among nurses in the
north of england
i'm disgusted and and outraged
um and it's not only about the share and
how hard people have worked and how
people have stepped up and kind of
listened to the challenge
of this you know unprecedented year that
we've never seen
it it's not even about that it's about
the disrespect from the government and
not recognizing the skills
that we have as a workforce defending
the offer
a government spokesman told sky news
over 1 million
nhs staff continue to benefit from
multi-year pay deals
agreed with trade unions which have
delivered a pay rise of over
12 percent for newly qualified nurses
and will increase junior doctors pay
scales by 8.2
the independent pay review bodies will
report in late spring
and we'll consider their recommendations
carefully
when we receive them labor has accused
the chancellor of failing to mention nhs
pay
in the budget and sneaking out the offer
the following day
shocking it's a kick in the teeth to our
hard-working
brave nhs staff they've been on the
front line in this crisis
hundreds have lost their lives and for
rishi sunak to offer
just a one percent pay rise which could
be a pay cut
if the estimates for inflation come true
is a disgrace nurses leaders point out
that more than 900 frontline nhs staff
have died as a result of coronavirus
during the pandemic
and while the government says one
percent is not a done deal
it's already facing a fierce backlash
john craig sky news
well the health minister nadine doris
joins me now good morning to you
um after everything doctors and nurses
have done for us over the
the last year the sacrifices they've
made
is a one percent pay increase enough
well of course we recognize the
sacrifice and the commitment
and vocation of nurses and all health
workers over the past year
we've all been touched by all personally
experienced by
help from nhs workers but i think it's
important to note that
the priority of the government has been
about protecting people's livelihoods
about continuing the furlough scheme
about fighting the pandemic
and and we've put huge effort into that
and we did not want nurses to go
unrecognized or doctors
and no other public sector employee
is receiving a pay rise there has been a
pay freeze
but the one percent offer is the most we
think we can afford which we have put
forward
to the pay review body that will be um
discussed that we will wait for feedback
from unions and other
health sector stakeholders and
and see where we move to on this but the
one percent is what the government can
afford
it's what the offer is and you know it
would be wrong to say
that a single person in the government
does not appreciate the effort of nurses
we absolutely do
but you you've been a nurse yourself i
mean what we're talking about here is an
extra three pound fifty
take home um for experienced nurses a
week
that that isn't enough what they're
saying to us is it it seems like an
insult
well as john's report said before i came
on
nurses have had a 12 increase in pay
over the last three years the average
nurse's salary is around
quite rightly 34 000 per annum
but i'm afraid at this moment in time at
the tail end of a pandemic
and at this time last year we were just
looking in the face of this global
pandemic
and we all know what the last year has
held and what we've had to go through
and that has been a huge amount of
expense
on on fighting the pandemic and keeping
to our best
possible way as a result of the efforts
of nhs staff people safe
keeping people safe is our priority now
protecting livelihoods
and and people's futures jobs businesses
making sure people can stay employment
extending the further scheme
those have to be our priorities now it
has to be about protecting
people and livelihoods now that we've
saved lives
hand on heart can you look at nhs
workers in the face and say
you know you you are not our priority at
this moment in time because that seems
to be what you're saying no because
that's not true
as i said no other public sector
employee
is receiving any pay rise there has been
a pay freeze
the nhs workers are going to receive a
pay rise but as i said there are still
changes going as your report said
there are still pay uplifts coming
through from the agenda for change
nurses have received a 12 pay rise over
the last year and quite rightly so
and and their salary is now an average
of 34 000 pounds a year
we wanted to you personally as a health
minister
and as a previously you were a nurse
would you like to see them
get more than one percent in an ideal
world is that what you would like to see
everybody in an ideal world would love
to see nurses paid
far more in an ideal world but we are
coming out of a pandemic
where we have seen huge borrowing and
cost to the government
you know only a year ago this week when
we had really no idea what was
coming at us and you know we've come
through this as a
as a country with a huge effort
from both nurses and doctors and all
healthcare workers
we have come through we're coming out
the end of this pandemic now
and the priority has to be about saving
people's jobs
which is why the furlough scheme has
been extended until the autumn
is this something that that would have
been imposed by the the treasury would
there have been disagreements between
the treasury and the department of
health
that's way above my pay scale i have no
idea of
any disagreements or any discussions i
know what we can afford though i know
what we've spent we all know what we've
spent and everyone knows
the efforts that the chancellor has put
in to make sure and to ensure this
government
protects people's jobs all the way
through this pandemic
and continuing now until the future
until we know we're well and truly out
of the other side
the calling thing for many uh in the nhs
is in real terms this is actually
a pay cut if inflation uh is uh
predicted to rise as has been suggested
well even john ashworth said um in your
report if the predictions come true we
don't know
what the future holds we know that at
the moment you know we spent
10 years following a labor government
fixing the economy
what we need to do now is to make sure
we keep fixing the hole in that roof
to keep a stable enough and economy
stable
moving forward and the only way we can
keep the economy stable is to protect
people's jobs
so that they have jobs to go back to to
protect businesses so they're there to
offer employment in the future
and that's where our priority has to be
you know it's like anyone in any home
you have a priority on your purse and
our priority
is about keeping people in work and
protecting people's jobs
that's the choice we've had to make
moving forward and you know
as i said again no other public sector
employee
is receiving any pay offer over the next
year
this is a recommendation from the
government which has gone to the public
at the pay review board that has gone
forward as a recommendation
we it would there was an offer made
to there has been an offer made to the
pay review board we hope
that that will be accepted because it's
what the government can afford
if the um pay review board comes back
and says actually that this is derisory
um and enforces that on the government
that they actually have to increase the
the the pay offered to nhs staff is that
something you would would welcome well
they are discussions for the future and
the discussions that the
uh the hancock uh the secretary of state
and
the treasury and others will have as i
say at this moment in time
our our priority is protecting jobs it's
about extending the furlough and
it's about making ensuring that we made
an offer
to the nhs because you know they the
huge effort
if there are not words to express how
grateful
everyone has been to they don't feel
that those in the nhs don't feel as if
that the government is grateful by any
stretch of the imagination we all
remember the
the clap for the nhs going out and
seeing shots of
rishi sunak and boris johnson clapping
hands for the nhs this morning they're
saying that it doesn't feel as though
their efforts
have been welcomed and have been
received and certainly not reflected in
this one percent
pay increase that's being proposed well
i hope nurses recognize that it's this
government
which has given them the 12 increase
over the past three years in their pay
and that we have acknowledged their
their effort and their contribution
by making a recommendation to the pay
review body this time
um as i said quite rightly the average
nurse pay is now at 34 000 pounds per
annum that's happened under this
government
and and we're proud of that and and
quite rightly nurses you know they're
we owe so much to them but at this
moment
in time having faced the year that we
have with this pandemic
i think some have described you know the
but can you understand though
why sorry to interrupt but i just want
to get to the crux of this really can
you
understand why they are so disappointed
this morning
yes of course i can understand anyone
can understand
but i want every nurse and every doctor
to know we are
hugely grateful to you but that the
government has
to make set priorities and our
priorities have had to be
saving people's jobs extending furlough
offering business grants so that
businesses can keep running about
keeping people
in employment so that you know without a
good economy without those businesses
without people in employment
we need that money to continue funding
our nhs
our world-class nhs and so that had to
be the government's priority
you've obviously explained the the
government's importance that they
they hold the uh nhs in high regard but
the institute of fiscal studies
um they criticized the budget for having
implausibly low spending plans including
excuse me a 30 billion pound reduction
in health care budgets
next year now i'm wondering why you
would think that public spending
should be lower than it was a year ago
pre-covered
well that's absolutely not true and
um i think that that was disabused
yesterday
that 30 billion i believe was
a reduction on the pandemic spending
it's not there is there are actually
real time
increases going into the nhs budget
year on year that figure i'm afraid is
completely wrong
that's not on our annual funding of the
nhs
that was on our pandemic budget which is
completely separate
but uh this is correct me if i'm wrong
on these figures three billion has been
allocated to bringing
waiting lists down in uh 2021 to 22.
that's one of the areas that you've
injected cash into
but 1.3 billion has been spent by
hospitals on
adapting to the virus so when you put
them side by side
you can see that the shortfall
there are absolutely no cuts moving
forward
to frontline nhs services either in
um waiting lists accidents and accident
and emergency
um there's just no cuts moving forward
there are
real-time increases going into the nhs
budget
so i'm afraid that isn't right there are
no cuts to nhs budgets
moving forward we have obviously
allocated huge amounts of money to
dealing with the pandemic which was
required
obviously as we get on top of pandemic
as the vaccine rollout continues
then we're not going to need as much
money to to fight the virus
in the way that we have done over the
past year and there were i
believe you will see the reductions but
in terms of the real-time nhs budget
there are no reductions okay dean doris
thank you very much for speaking to me
this morning health minister there
joining me now political correspondent
rob powell uh she was
absolutely adamant no cuts to frontline
services adamant about that yeah and
whilst
she's right that there's no reduction in
spending what there is if you look back
at the budget last march what they set
out for spending on day-to-day
spending public spending they are now
planning to spend less which does beg
the question what's changed over the
last 12 months to make you think
that public services need less money
than you thought they needed
um last march so it's not necessarily
cuts but it is cuts to planned spending
and i think that is linked to that
accusation that there's not there wasn't
enough in the budget
to cater for the ongoing demand not just
in the nhs but also in
other public services like schools as
well that there wasn't enough in there
on that not just to deal with backlogs
but clearly as well to give nhs workers
a pay rise and on that nadine doris
was adamant that one percent was all the
government could afford and even though
she denied it when you put it to her
that this means that nhs workers aren't
your priority
she did say that actually their priority
at the moment was things like the
furlough scheme was business grants
what's keeping the economy going and
because of spending money on that
there isn't money to spend on giving nhs
workers a pay rise
higher than one percent i thought she
did also say though that they'd continue
to engage they'd get feedback from the
unions i think we can all imagine what
that feedback will consist of
and then we will see where we move to so
i think this is
as in any pay discussion between the
governments and the public sector
um something of an opening bargaining
position
i think the damage to the danger for the
government
is that by setting their opening
position quite so
low they do risk uh they do run the risk
of looking
just a little bit ungrateful okay but
not set in stone as
yet yeah rob at the moment thank you
still to come on the program at half
past seven we'll be getting
more reaction to the nhs prey review
with the shadow health secretary
jonathan ashworth a five past eight
we'll hear from the general secretary of
the national association of head
teachers
who's warning that unsustainable
pressure on school staff could put the
government's education recovery plan
at risk and at 20 to 9 we'll hear from
the chief executive of the uk's first
lgbt plus retirement home set to open
in london later this year
now there could be some good news for
sun seekers this morning after cyprus
said british tourists who've had
both covid vaccine doses will be allowed
to holiday
quarantine free from may the first it'll
be welcome news for holidaymakers
as new research shows the price of
domestic getaways
is set to shoot up this summer
correspondent ender brady joins me now
from uh the newsroom and uh and uh
some good news uh of sort uh it's gonna
be cheaper to uh
jet away rather than stay at home yeah
interesting jillian two strands to the
travel story today so if we look at the
staycation
story first of all this has come from
which the consumer affairs magazine
their researchers looked at the 10 most
popular uk
seaside locations and they compared and
contrasted last summer's prices
with summer 2021 and the end result is
they found that prices are up
uh by an average of around 35 percent so
you're looking at resorts like st
dives whitby clandudnow and brighton
and just in real terms the biggest
markup a one bed masonette in brighton
for one night
53 pounds a night last summer 127 pounds
this summer
uh clan dude now for a week last summer
427 pounds
uh this summer 596 and saint ives a week
there last summer would have cost
860 pounds this summer 1263.
now on the foreign travel front cyprus
some interesting news this morning the
government in cyprus saying
that from may the first any british
visitors
who have had both jobs will be allowed
in for a holiday
no negative tests required and no
quarantine
british tourists are the biggest market
in cyprus
tourism accounting for 13 percent of the
cypriot economy
but last year of course they had a
really shocking year 85 percent drop
because of the pandemic and it would
appear that the cypriot government just
kind of
getting their word in early that they
will be welcoming british guests and
visitors
as of may the first but of course as
things stand right now under the prime
minister's road map out of lockdown
foreign travel is actually banned until
may 17th at the very earliest
ender thank you
australia has asked the european
commission to review its decision to
block a shipment of astrazeneca's
coronavirus vaccine
the block supported italy's decision to
bar the planned export of around 250 000
doses of the vaccine after the drug
company failed to meet its supply
commitments to the bloc
australians finance minister simon
birmingham suggested the eu
is trying to tear up the rule book
we've contracted up to 150 million doses
of vaccines
including 50 million doses to be
produced here in australia
at the csl facilities so that was about
ensuring that we
built in contingencies for the
likelihood that things would go wrong
the world is in
quite unchartered territory at present
it's unsurprising that some countries
will tear up the rule book
when they're in uncharted territory and
that's why we've taken these very
cautious approaches
let's take a look now the latest
coronavirus figures in the uk
on a further 6573 new confirmed cases of
curvid19
were recorded in the uk within the last
24 hours
242 people have died within 28 days of
testing positive
bringing the total to 124 025
and 20.98 million first doses of the
vaccine
have been administered
also making the news this morning a
tsunami warnings
forced thousands in new zealand to
evacuate their homes this morning
after one of the region's most powerful
earthquakes ever
an 8.1 magnitude quake struck off the
north island just hours after two
earlier quakes
registering 7.4 and 7.3
small tsunami waves and wave surges were
seen but no damage was recorded
and warnings have since been lifted
pope francis is heading to iraq to urge
the country's dwindling number of
christians
to stay put and rebuild after years of
war
the pontiff is breaking his year-long
coveted lockdown for the four-day visit
in which he also aims to encourage the
improvement of muslim
christian relations in the area
school leaders are warning the
unsustainable pressure on staff
could put the government's education
recovery plans at risk
the union of head teachers have raised
concerns that the stress the pandemic
has put on schools
could lead to an exodus of teaching
staff
the government isn't doing enough to
achieve zero emissions by 2050 according
to a new report
the public accounts committee said there
was no coordinated plan
or milestone to achieve the goal almost
two years after it was made into law
it comes as the uk prepares to host the
united nations climate summit
in glasgow this november
recognition as spacex launches more
satellite
and test rockets that could be used to
go to mars
the government has published plans to
allow space flights to launch from
british soil
it's proposing to build spaceports in
several locations across
the country including cornwall snowdonia
and
glasgow presswick airport
schools that teach vulnerable and
disadvantaged pupils say they're being
forced to cut
services and make teachers redundant
because of a severe drop
in funding during the pandemic pupil
referral units say they're concerned
that as schools return in england
they'll struggle to cope with the
expected increase in demand
our political correspondent rob powell
reports
smoothing a path through the roughest of
times
josh was referred to the youth challenge
academy in bolton
just under three years ago after being
excluded for fighting i kid hit me a few
times in it and then
i hit him back once i got in trouble
the teachers at mainstream they're a lot
more like
strict so you have to master your stuff
yeah they help you with it though they
want
the academies here also teach vulnerable
pupils and those who are at risk of
exclusion
kobit has seen a move to some online
teaching but for coden
who started here after going to four
mainstream schools
learning at home would have been tough i
wouldn't have had space to concentrate
because i've got
like two little sisters and obviously my
mum and my mum
and we've got a dog so it's just that
hectic in my house so you can't
concentrate on
one bit like other pupil referral units
bolton impact trust gets a large part of
its funding
on a per head basis but with schools
shut
there's been 70 fewer pupils here
knocking budgets off balance by around 1
million pounds
as a result the head is having to make
around 20 redundancies
and cut some services just as demand is
expected to increase
the intelligence on the ground from our
commissioners and from our secondary
school heads
and from our primary colleagues is that
there's going to be a real need for our
provision
um after the 8th of march of course we
will endeavor to support all of the
children who are referred through to us
but i'm doing it on a threadbare
staffing at the moment
across the sector school leaders say
they're feeling the squeeze
the department for education told us it
was monitoring demand and funding
and pointed to an ongoing review it says
will ensure money is allocated in a fair
way
the challenge the government has though
is covid has hit the most vulnerable
and disadvantaged pupils hardest
potentially widening the attainment gap
put bluntly the pandemic has leveled
down and made it harder to level up
we need to make sure that the catch-up
program announced by the government
the extra tuition is focused
on disadvantaged pupils and
disadvantaged
schools to make sure that those who have
suffered the most
um have the best chance to get back on
that education ladder of opportunity
back in bolton and in the primary group
eleven-year-old bayley says home
learning
has been tough on his friends they've
just been really lonely
and so what we did at school is
we made these like home survival kits
because we're doing like bear grylls at
the moment we did like these home
survival kits and sent them off to them
but dexter who started here in september
is optimistic
now i've come here it's just gone above
and beyond i just
my teachers say that i've really
improved
schools like this say they're likely to
be needed more than ever in the coming
months
as a global challenge shapes a
generation of young minds
rob powell sky news in bolton
time for a look at the weather now with
naz good morning
it's turn chilly again hasn't it
yeah it is quite chilly in some spots
where we've had clear spells overnight
but
it's looking like a fine day today we've
got high pressure in charge and it
looks to be settled in fact for the rest
of the week
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we're going to see a lot of
dry and bright weather for the rest of
this week but nights
will be chilly still in some spots there
will be frosty conditions as well
in fact it is quite a cold start out
there this morning there's a fair amount
of cloud around but there have been some
clear spells through the night and
under those clearer skies there have
been frosty conditions developing as
well
but it's mainly dry except for a few
showers across parts of the north and
east maybe a few of them wintry but
very isolated ones and then going into
this afternoon we'll see some bright or
sunny spells and mainly dry conditions
continue
but there may be your shower to around
central and eastern areas and there will
be a fair amount of clouds
but in between there will be some sunny
spells the rest of the sunshine for the
north west i think
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come on sky news breakfast as a
proposed pay rise for nhs staff is
branded pitiful
we'll get reaction from the shadow
health secretary jonathan ashworth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the government has defended
its decision to offer health care
workers
a pay rise of one per cent saying its
priority is to protect
jobs speaking to me earlier this hour
the health minister nadine dori said the
government
recognized the sacrifice and commitment
nhs workers have made over the past
year but the one percent is all they can
afford
of course we recognize the sacrifice and
the commitment
and vocation of nurses and all health
workers over the past year
we've all been touched by or personally
experienced by
help from nhs workers but i think it's
important to note that
the priority of the government has been
about protecting people's livelihoods
about continuing the furlough scheme
about fighting the pandemic and and
we've put
huge effort into that and we did not
want nurses to go
unrecognized or doctors and no other
public sector employee is receiving a
pay rise there has been a pay freeze
but the one percent offer is the most we
think we can afford which we have put
forward
to the pay review body that will be um
discussed that we will wait for feedback
from unions and other
health sector stakeholders and
and see where we move to on this but the
one percent is what the government can
afford
we're joined now by the shadow health
secretary jonathan ashworth good morning
to you and you heard it there from
nadine doris one percent is all the
government can afford
oh shocking disgusting an absolute kick
in the teeth we've got nhs staff on the
front line
battling to save people's lives we've
got nhs staff delivering the vaccination
program
and a one percent pay rise is derivate
and in fact if the estimates for
inflation
come true it's a pay cut this government
is cutting the pay of nurses who are
fighting to save the lives of covid
patients
they should be ashamed so you simply
don't accept
the excuse that there isn't the money to
increase the
the pay rise to more than one percent
no not remotely government is about
making choices
this government has chosen to offer just
a one percent
increase for nurses and paramedics and
midwives
while at the same time they are are
spending
uh millions on ppe that was duff
and they're not trying to get the money
back from companies uh i'm talking about
hundreds of millions here
from companies who delivered duff ppe
that we couldn't even use
they're spending thousands of pounds a
day on highly paid
private sector consultants in the
testing and trace program
they could have chosen a different path
and given our nhs staff
a fair deal and i would urge rishi
tsunak
to think again but but do you accept
that they
are the only public sector workers to
receive a
a pay increase or will be in line for
pay increase there's been a freeze
elsewhere in the public sector
well public sector workers who have kept
our society
running in this crisis they should be
properly
rewarded for that and a one percent
i'd say a one percent pay increase if
inflation
runs at higher than one percent as the
bank of england and others are
predicting
that's a pay cut they're cutting the pay
of nurses so it's all very well boris
johnson and rishi sunac standing
standing on their doorsteps and
applauding the nhs staff and having
their photos taken and putting it on
instagram
and twitter when it came to it they
cut the pay of nhs staff i just think it
is shocking
but sadly i'm not actually shocked that
they've done it
i mean it is just a proposal though at
this stage i mean it has to go before
the nhs pay
review body um so this might just be the
the opening bargaining chip do you think
well if that's the case then
let's set a commitment from the
government that they will honor whatever
the pay review body recommend
because the worry is that the pay review
body may well recommend
a more generous settlement quite rightly
but the government will reject that
recommendation
and just offer one percent so if that
line now is oh this is just the start of
the process
let's see what the pay review body says
let's get a cast iron commitment
that they will honor the pay review
body's recommendations
and do you think that's likely no i
don't
to be frank i mean excuse me if wish you
soon that had
was serious about giving our nhs staff a
pay rise he would announce it in his
budget
instead he rather cowardly allowed it to
be sneaked out yesterday
and when we spotted the small print
that's when people realized what what a
derisively offer was on the car i was on
the table
what what do you think that the reasons
were for it not being included
in the budget because which is ashamed
and he was too cowardly to stand up
there at the dispatch box
and be level with the british people
about his pay cut for nhs staff
so we try to hide it try to sneak it
through
it's appalling behavior to be frank
um despite uh your um
negative comments about the the budget
um yougov are putting the conservatives
at 13 points ahead
of labor um and this after the budget as
we discussed
announcing the biggest tax rises in 30
years why do you think
that labour is still in this position
well you know labor's got a long way to
go so
excuse me um do you beg your pardon and
labor's got a long way to go to rebuild
the trust of the british people we all
recognize that we just had a
horrendous horrendous election defeat
back in 2019 the worst
in our history but i mean to be frank my
focus is on
supporting the response to covet
and hoping that we have the best
possible response to covert in this
country and we can save as many lives as
possible so
you know opinion polls will come and go
but dealing with this pandemic is my
focus and priority
but 55 of people uh actually describing
the budget as as fair
well it will be fair for those people
who
um um you know aren't paying more tax
but i mean there's a big
big big group of people who are going to
be paying more income taxes result
and i think when people realize that
they'll see that the tory party can
never again
claim to be the party of low taxation
they are actually dragging a lot of
middle-income earners a lot of
hard-working families into paying more
income tax
so nurses and teachers and police
officers will be paying more
tax thanks to rishi sunak this isn't a
low tax party this is now the high tax
party
and i think when people start feeling
the direct
impact of that on their own finances i
think the view of this budget will
change rapidly
and it's been said uh many times that
we're dealing with unprecedented times
what would labour have done differently
well i think you need to grow your way
out of this crisis
um this isn't you know this isn't a time
for
uh austerity and cutbacks uh and uh
you know an obsession with um the the
deficit we've got to grow the economy
we've got to
support jobs and livelihoods and the
mistake that rishi sunat made
is that he's clobbering a lot of
middle-income families
with big tax increases and he is not at
the same time
giving out public services like the nhs
the resources they need in fact
the overall health budgets will be cut
next year
or uh by 30 billion pounds so i think
that there's always i i think the
long-term
ramifications of this budget will come
to the fore
and people will actually look back and
say it wasn't a fair budget it was
actually a deeply
unfair budget and a very unpopular
budget but
but people will will will will want to
look we'll want to see the impact of
these
different measures on their own incomes
and when they do see that i think
they'll see that
uh wish you soon as increasing the tax
taxes on people
okay john ashworth shadow health center
thank you very much for speaking to us
this morning i'll leave you to go off
and deal with that cough
yes i need to get got a water sorry
about that
no no problem at all
now sites such as amazon and waterstones
are being urged to add
warning tags to anti-vaccination books
as an investigation by sky news
reveals some have become best sellers
since the start of the pandemic
sky samia burgess reports
jab takes the country closer to
defeating covid19
but worries continue that misinformation
is putting some off from having the
vaccine
and you can buy that misinformation in
bookshops
sky news has found that booksellers
water stones
amazon and foils are selling
anti-vaccine books
most of the reviews of this top seller
on amazon were posted
since march 2020 suggesting
purchases increased after the pandemic
began
many of them gave five-star ratings of
the book
which is also sold by foils shadow
health minister alex norris
calls for retailers to do more i don't
think it would be a solution to
you know burn the books or throw them
all away because actually i think the
mystique would grow in that
but instead you know we'd really welcome
a sense of proportionate health warnings
as
we've started to see emerge online
anti-vaccine books
are regularly appearing in the top 10
bestsellers in the children's
vaccination category on amazon
in this recent screenshot half of the
top books
are promoting vaccine misinformation it
included one book
which claims data had been widely
manipulated and misrepresented
and that major safety questions have
gone unanswered about the vaccine
it's also available on waterstones
free speech campaigners say any calls
for these books to be banned
should be resisted almost anything can
potentially cause harm
under certain circumstances so if you
grant yourself that right you're
granting yourself the right to ban
almost anything sky news also found
other examples of medical misinformation
for sale
like this book which claims aids isn't
contagious
research has found 10 percent of
vaccine-related search results on amazon
led to products promoting misinformation
we also found out that
once users start engaging with
misinformation on the platform
they are presented with more
misinformation and at various points in
their
amazon navigation ground all the authors
of the texts included in this report
deny that they are spreading
misinformation or our anti-vaccine
in response to our findings water stones
and foils
said the books they sell do not reflect
the company's views
while amazon said it encourages
customers to read official sources of
information
and will remove products that breach
amazon's guidelines
samuel burgess sky news
now the national trust has drawn up
climate change
map plotting threats to its stately
homes landscapes and coastlines
the tool outlines risks posed by extreme
heat floods
high winds and landslides and how they
could impact
the trust sites i'm joined now by keith
jones a climate change advisor
at the national trust good morning to
you um
so what exactly does the the map reveal
what are the the various risks
well we started from a point of if
you're planning for climate change you
need to know
where you're starting from what are you
facing what are the hazards
uh that you're facing into so that was
the premise behind all of the work
because we're already seeing changes
we're already seeing impacts
but we needed to look at how bad can it
get and where is it going to affect the
most
and therefore everything from landslides
to soil shrinkage
to high winds we've mapped as much as we
can so far but
it's still a developing area but we can
see the hot spots we can see the areas
in the country
where we are most exposed to these
factors
from there we can start planning without
knowing what you're facing into you
can't
really look at the whole thing and look
at where do i start
so where are the hot spots what what are
what are they facing in those areas
well if it's the southeast it's going to
be overheating we've seen quite a lot of
areas that will be
over 30 degrees centigrade for 15 days
or more
per annum which sounds lovely but you're
talking
in the middle of london you could be
talking about over 40 degrees
which i wouldn't like to be in you're
talking of increasing storms in the west
side of the country
more drought onto it so everything
combined shows
it's not a good place this future
climate uh
area but it's not set in stone it is it
is
uh the worst case if as we cut carbon i
hope as we cut it as early as possible
it doesn't have to be i think we're
trying to be really clear on that
we're planning for the worst but we're
hoping for the best
so what are the things that that we can
do to offset the risk you've
mentioned reduced uh carbon what else is
there to be done
from my side it's slowing the flow of
rivers keeping the water in catchments
more natural shading it's called
nature-based solutions
trees are really good not just for
carbon sequestration but also for
cooling uh areas
for enabling wildlife to move
so we we've picked up a really nice one
in snowdonia where we've used an
old approach to stop the wind-driven
rain going into the gable ends of
buildings that are exposed
it's called slate hanging so we're also
learning from the past to plan for the
future as well
and what are some of the other things
that uh your sites are doing to to try
and sort of
ward off your worst case scenario
well i i because the uncertainty in the
future
we're reacting to what we've got now so
for example you've got
castles up to a thousand years old that
now getting rainfall they've never had
before
so when a simple thing is making the
gutters bigger and deeper and wider
so we've done that in quite a few places
we're looking at the drainage element
we're looking at the
overheating closing curtains ham house
for example in
its walled garden uh in london in
high temperatures is running a
mediterranean opening hours
for the volunteers there to enable that
they're not there during the hottest
part of the day
so it it's all it's horses for courses
but of course we're
just at the leading edge of this at the
moment we're not looking at we're not
experiencing the worst case
we're just picking up that the canary is
in the mine and it's singing now
yeah start early in canva the worst case
scenario keith jones thank you very much
for sharing your work with us thank you
thank you still to come on a sky news
breakfast
could businesses be hurt in the
chancellor's plan to rise
corporation tax we're joined by the
founder of phones for you next
it wasn't an easy decision to make but i
think when my husband was
um faced with his difficulties and we
had to make a decision as to where our
lives were going
it just seemed like a um a pretty easy
decision at that time
um it's something that i'd always been
quite passionate about but i think when
you fall into
a career that you're quite comfortable
in and you're getting okay getting on
okay with you you don't really think
about sort of moving
um until such significant things happen
in your life
i have so much to be thankful for um
like i said if it wasn't for the nhs
i i wouldn't be here but the fact that
um
my husband was also you know as
well as a family if it wasn't for the
nhs i don't think
any of us would be sort of leading the
the lives that we are
so um so it was the it's the best way to
be able to give back
and there has i mean historically
there's been shortages i think for as
long as we can remember
and again the route into getting into
nursing has has become a little bit
more diffic and difficult especially for
those that i've already established in
other careers
however now um there is so many
different routes in
um not just like myself i actually
managed to do an apprenticeship
which meant that i didn't even have the
pressure the financial pressures of
having to
um start a new career i was actually
supported all the way
and so if anybody's actually considering
it i would say
um go for it there are so many
opportunities out there
and it's not even just nursing there's
so many different careers within the nhs
so even if you're
in i.t or if you're in engineering or if
there's
any other area that you may be
interested in electricians
everything everyone's needed so i would
definitely consider it
[Music]
[Music]
does anyone know which particular parts
of your body can be damaged by air
pollution
[Music]
most places will be fine this afternoon
with bright or sunny spells although
there will be a fair amount of cloud
around as well
a few light showers are possible across
central and eastern areas
but otherwise the majority of the uk and
island will be mainly
dry and feeling fairly fine in any
bright or sunny spells too
so taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being very high
most places will be at a low level of 1
to 3 today and that's due to the mostly
fine
dry and settled conditions
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
now as the chancellor looks to stem
spiraling debt and balance the books
after the pandemic
in the budget rishi sunat set out plans
to raise corporation tax
it's set to go up to 25 from 19
starting in 2023 joining me now to
discuss how this might impact business
is the entrepreneur behind phones for
you john caldwell
good morning to you uh thank you for
joining us what what does this 25
mark mean for you in terms of
corporation tax the rise from 19
well i don't think it's uh overly
significant for existing businesses
because we have as richie says got one
of the lowest corporation taxes
in the world and so it's still a great
place to do business
but clearly for anybody coming into the
uk or thinking of coming into the uk
it is six percent eroded away from their
potential profitabilities
and so it is a deterrent it doesn't mean
they won't come but it won't be so
attractive
now as long as rishi uses that six
percent game
to incentivize inward investment into
the uk and this is
absolutely what we need to do we've got
to grow the uk economy
so that we can grow revenues and work
our way out of debt
in the long term so as long as he does
that then i have no real objection to
the uh
increasing corporation tax uh and
alongside that of course he has kept the
the the rate lower to 19 on a taper
situation for the uh smaller businesses
um in general though do you think that
enough has been done to help businesses
on the road to
to recovery well in some ways yes
uh but the the there's the
real huge gaps that is left um the huge
gaps of course are excluded
who've been disastrously treated and i
don't understand why
and it's still not too late to put it
right although it looks as though
rishi's not going to do so
what are the gaps that you're referring
to
i'm sorry what are the gaps that you're
referring to the huge gaps you refer to
well there's lots of different gaps in
excluded where they're not
an example is that uh somebody who's
self-employed that earns over 50
000 pounds a year gets no help
whatsoever now
that's a preposterous notion you know if
somebody's p-a-y-e
employed by somebody and earns 200 000
pounds a year
they still get two and a half thousand
pounds so
why has he capped the self-employed who
arguably would need it
more because they've probably got
overheads associated with the business
so
there are a lot of cracks like that and
there's
there's too much detail to go into in
this program because
there's a different categories
of people who've been neglected but it's
a total of up to 3.8 million
as you say that there's much more detail
to to go into i'm afraid though that
we've run out of time uh thank you very
much for sharing your thoughts
with us thus far this morning thank you
thank you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning a lot of dry and bright
weather for the rest of this week but
nights will be chilly with frosty
conditions in fact there's apache frost
out there this morning
where there have been clear spells
overnight it's mainly dry though except
for the odd isolated maybe
wintry shower over northern and eastern
areas and we'll continue with bright or
sunny spells into this afternoon
fair amount of cloud around so the
sunshine hazing places but it will be
mainly dry except for the odd shower
over central and eastern aries